so before a business school I was a
strategy consultant I had reached a
plateau in my learning and I came to
business school in order to transition
to more entrepreneurial and operational
type of opportunities where I can make
an impact in the energy in an
environment spaces we we want to be a
data service provider for farmers and by
that I specifically mean we want to fly
drones over fields we want to take
pictures and do a lot of Atmospheric
Corrections and image processing to turn
those pictures into a composite image of
an entire farm we can then do more
advanced image processing to tell for
each and every pixel and hence each and
every plant what's the what's going on
with that plant we can tell all these
different informations that farmers can
use to make their next irrigation
decision for me like what I'm trying to
do whether it's being an entrepreneur
not is go through a creative process
where I can make an impact in a space
that I'm really passionate about which
is the environment entrepreneurship is a
very emotionally challenging experience
at times and it's helpful to have a
community like the venture studio to
provide support when when things are
challenging or rough when I've been
working on this my colleagues are both
in the engineering school and it was
important for me to have a community
that I could be a part of while pursuing
something like this it's really helpful
to have people that are going through
the same experiences the ups and downs
of raising funds and doing experimental
trials both from an emotional support
and then also a sharing of information
and best practices well if it works then
we can reduce water usage in California
in the world we can reduce fertilizer
usage which is great for the environment
about 90% of the world's water is used
in your irrigation for
like seeing farmers improved their their
livelihood and and reduced their
fertilizers which would in turn reduce
chemical usage in in the world that'd be
really meaningful to me and what I would
hope that we can accomplish it at a
grand scale if we can encourage adoption
of our technology to a certain scale